[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 12 octobre voici le programme de
ce soir dans les yelines une centaine
non environ 200 personnes se sont
réunies hier soir devant l'Hôtel de
Ville de Versailles un remblement pour
rendre hommage aux victimes de
l'offensive au Hamas en Israël dans les
ivelines une centaine d'élus
d'opposition se sont rassemblés au sein
d'un collectif issu de toute tendance
politique leur objectif est pourtant le
même réveiller la démocratie locale pour
cela ils ont émis une quinzaine de
propositions et le jeudi comme
d'habitude nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie dans les Yvelines au programme
exposition sensorielle fête de l'automne
ou encore foire médiéval les détails
avec notre journaliste Gabriel gonther
et PU puis l'invité du 78 en 2ème partie
d'émission nous parlerons du village
entrédent qui a lieu ce samedi au
château de plaisir et ce sera avec vous
Anne bakland bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes responsable de l'institut de
promotion de la santé de Saint-Quentin
en Eveline l'IPS qui organise la 4e
édition de l'entréd village ce samedi
l'objectif permettre aux aidents de
sortir de leur isolement de souffler et
d'échanger on en parlera tout à l'heure
plus en détail en fin d'émission avec
nous également sur ce plateau une
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir bonsoir mathil
vous allez nous présenter vos idées de
sorti tout à l'heure pour ce weekend
mais avant on va faire un point avec
vous sur les informations du jour à
retenir dans les
[Musique]
ivelines et on commence ces informations
Gabriel par le conflit entre le Hamas et
Israël ce dernier a des conséquences en
France le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
dararmanin a des dénoncé une
récrudescence d'actes antisémite oui et
parmi les personnes visées Gael Bron
pivé la députée des ivelines et
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
reçu des menaces de mort à son domicile
elle a d'ailleurs été placée sous
protection judiciaire à la suite d'un
incident qui s'est déroulé il y a 3
jours à l'Assemblée nationale la
parlementaire avait interdit l'accès à
l'hémicycle à une militante
palestinienne membre d'une association
classée terroriste par l'Union
européenne toujours sur le conflit entre
le Hamas et Israël un rassemblement a
été organisé hier à Versailles environ
200 personnes se sont mobilisées devant
l'Hôtel de Ville de Versailles
principalement issu de la communauté
juive un rassemblement qui avait pour
but de rendre hommage aux victimes de
l'attaque du Hamas en Israël on écoute
la réaction d'arier toleddano leurabinde
de versaill on voyait des personnes
s'approcher vers pr de la communauté
vers les fidèle vers moi-même me dire
combien ils étaient sensibles à ce que
nous
ressentons vraiment ça fait vraent chaud
au cœur ça fait vraiment des baomes au
cœur parce que cette fois-ci c'était
totalement unanime et on poursuit ces
informations Gabriel avec le verdict du
procès de l'attentat à maganville qui
est tombé il est tombé hier en fin
d'après-midi la cour d'assise spéciale
de Paris a condamné Mohamed Lamin
aberous à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité à sorti d'une peine de sûreté
de 22 ans il est reconnu coupable de
complicité pour le double assassinat de
Jessica schneeder et Jean-Baptiste
Salvin un couple de polici qui est tué à
leur domicile de Magnanville le 13 juin
2016 Mohamed Lamine aberou était le seul
accusé dans ce procès le terroriste
ayant été abattu par le Raid le jour de
l'attentat les avocats de la défense
font vont faire appel de cette
condamnation et on termine avec un mot
de rugby qui concerne le prochain
adversaire adversaire de l'équipe de
France à la Coupe du Monde oui l'Afrique
du Sud s'est entraîné aujourd'hui devant
la presse au centre d'entraînement de
croissie sur scène la ville ivelinoise
est le camp de base des champions du
monde anti jusqu'à leur quart de finale
les springbx affronteront les Bleus ce
dimanche à 21h au Stade de France bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag setweet
news la démocratie locale est-elle en
danger c'est en tout cas ce que pense
une centaine d'élus municipaux
d'opposition D courant septembre ils se
sont rassemblés à travers un collectif
ils ont ainsi rédigé une quinzaine de
propositions qu'ils ont pu présenter au
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher dans
les Yvelines un collectif de 98 élus
municipaux d'opposition vient de se
créer issu d'une quarantaine de communes
desvelines et de tout parti politique de
gauche comme de droite leur objectif est
pourtant le même réveiller la démocratie
locale comme beaucoup de mes concitoyens
j'avais le sentiment que Ben la
démocratie au niveau local local
fonctionnait bien je me suis très
rapidement rendu compte dans le cadre de
ce mandat que finalement bah la
démocratie est également en panne au
niveau local la démocratie effectivement
locale n'est pas chose aisée dans de
nombreuses communes moi j'ai eu à me
battre pendant 2 ans juste pour faire
reconnaître un simple droit d'expression
puisque notre notre Maire nous déignait
le la possibilité de nous exprimer à sa
convenance le problème n'est pas là mais
sur la page officielle Facebook de la
mairie alors qu'effectivement c'est
inscrit dans les dans les textes pour
avoir connaissance des documents et pour
pouvoir tout simplement essayer de
comprendre ce qui est prévu dans les
projets de la majorité c'est très
compliqué et on a du coup aucun espace
d'expression on n pas des on a que 500
caractères par exemple dans le bulletin
trimestriel mais on n'a pas accès à la
page Facebook on n' pas d'autres moments
d'expression et même en conseil c'est
très compliqué de de pouvoir s'exprimer
face à ce constat ils ont émis une
quinzaine de propositions comme la
création d'un observato national de la
démocratie locale ou une révision de la
prime majoritaire la prime majoritaire
c'est une aberération démocratique
c'est-à-dire que elle est aujourd'hui à
50 % ça veut dire que si vous arrivez en
tête vous récupérez déjà 50 % des sièges
au niveau au niveau du conseil municipal
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans
une ville par exemple où il y a il y a
eu 32 voix d'écart il y a 23 voix pour
la 23 sièges pardon pour la majorité et
et 7 pour l'opposition fin septembre ces
propositions on été présenté au
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher ce
dernier s'est montré attentif sur
certains points d'ici un mois les élus
d'opposition souhaitent lancer leur
propre baromètre de la démocratie locale
dans les yvenines en fonction des
résultats le collectif demandera une
entrevue avec le préfet des
yvenines avec l'arrivée des Jeux
olympiques de nombreuses gares
franiliennes vont être réaménagé
nouveaux ascenseurs qui rallongé
l'objectif est de permettre une
meilleure accessibilité des personnes à
mobilité réduite à la la gare de
Villepreux les clés des travaux ont
débuté en juillet dernier et devrai
s'achever en avril 2024 le maire desclés
sous-bois Philippe guigen a répondu aux
questions de Julien
[Musique]
Leroi dans le cadre des Jeux Olympiques
beaucoup de gares vont être réaménagé
dans cet objectif PMR bien que n'étant
pas une une une ville avec des sites
olympiques nous avons uniquement un site
d'entraînement nous avons souhaité nous
avons agi de manière à ce que cette
cette gare soit totalement
réhabilitée il va y avoir deux nouveaux
deux nouveaux ascenseurs il va y avoir
un des rallongement de Cais il va il va
y avoir des des dalles podotactiles il
va y avoir une remise à niveau de tout
ce qui est éclairage il va y avoir à
l'intérieur une accessibilité aussi au
niveau des guichets euh et puis euh à
l'extérieur il va y avoir des une une
sortie qui n'était pas
[Musique]
prévue lorsque nous avons fait notre
première réunion avec la SNCF il nous a
été affirmé nous serons très vigilant à
contrôler cela que le le le bruit sera
très très très réduit il va y avoir des
travaux qui vont durer la nuit de
manière à essayer de perturber le moins
possible la l'ensemble des habitants que
ce soit les habitants de ce côté de C de
la gare ou de ou de l'autre côté avec
une une une plage horaire de euh
0h30 du matin jusqu'à jusqu'à 4h30 plus
un certain nombre de de weekends qu' on
déjà été euh planifiés un minimum de 8
[Musique]
weekends et au total le coût des travaux
s'élève à 11,5 millions d'euros
direction Versailles à présent depuis
mardi les membres du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature sont en mission
d'information auprès de la Cour d'appel
à Versailles l'occasion de faire le
point sur les difficultés auxquelles ils
sont confrontés c'est le reportage de
Clara de
Frutos ils sont venus prendre le pou de
la justice la cour d'appel de Versailles
accueille depuis mardi le plus haut
magistrat de France pour une mission
d'information ça consiste pour le
conseil à comprendre le mieux possible
le fonctionnement de la Cour d'appel les
différents problèmes auxquels la cour
d'appel peut être confrontée accompagné
de h autres membres du Conseil le
premier président de la Cour de
cassation doit rencontrer et
s'entretenir avec des magistrats mais
pas queux pour mieux comprendre nous
essayons de rencontrer le maximum de
personnes à la fois les chefs de la cour
d'appel le premier président et le
procureur général mais aussi la
directrice de Greff la directrice du des
services administratifs et c'est comme
ça que nous avons une idée aussi
complète que possible du fonctionnement
de la Cour d'appel c'est ces
déplacements ont aussi pour objectif de
remplir un rôle majeur la nomination des
magistrats c'est le Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature lui-même qui propose
donc qui choisit en fait ceux qui vont
occuper ses fonctions c'est le cas par
exemple pour un président de tribunal un
premier président de cour d'appel ou
quel un membre de la Cour de cassation
et puis dans toujours dans cette
activité de nomination pour les autres
fonctions le Conseil donne un accord
mais la proposition est faite par le
gouvernement au cours de cette mission
de 3 jours la délégation s'est aussi
rendue dans les différents tribunaux
judiciaires qui composent la cour de
Versailles ils s'étendent sur quatre
départements les Yvelines les hautes
scènes leuréloire et le
valdoise allez c'est l'heure à présent
de passer à notre page
[Musique]
loisir et on ouvre cette page loisir
avec vos idées de sortie pour ce weekend
dans lesivvelin Gabriel et on commence
avec une sortie insolite je vous propose
Mathilde un voyage dans le temps
direction l'époque médiévale pour ça
nous partons à Châteaufort où la foire
Saint-Simon revient pour une 37e édition
comme chaque année vous serez plongé
quelques siècles en arrière pour
retrouver l'ambiance et les us et
coutumes du Moyen-Âge l'occasion de
rencontrer saltin ban sorcière et
gentilhomme mais aussi de tester les
spécialités culinaires et les activités
artisanales d'autrefis cette année la
fauonnerie est à l'honneur grâce à la
troupe Les Ailes de l'urga de quoi vivre
le temps d'un weekend comme au 13e
siècle et après avoir voyagé dans le
temps pourquoi ne pas voyager dans
l'espace et s'offrir explorer le ciel
étoilé c'est en tout cas un des
objectifs de l'événement national le
jour de la nuit c'est l'occasion unique
d'explorer le ciel étoilé tout en
sensibilisant à la pollution lumineuse
notamment en éteignant une partie de
l'éclairage public samedi soir la
projection du documentaire lumière sur
la ville sera proposée un film sur les
enjeux et les conséquences de la
pollution lumineuse des experts en
astronomie seront présents pour échanger
la soirée se déroule à la mairie de
plaisir et dans le parc du château vous
pouvez consulter le site qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran pour voir les
communes qui participent une sortie
sport maintenant avec de l'aquathlon
l'Union Sportive de viroflet organise
dimanche 15 octobre la la deuxème série
Aquathlon des bertisettes alors Mathilde
est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est
l'aquatlon alors non pas vraiment mais à
image j'ai vu une personne qui nage et
une personne qui court dans la forêt
donc c'est à peu près ça le principe les
participants enchaînent une épreuve de
natation dans la piscine de la ville et
une course à pied dans la forêt l'année
dernière une centaine de sportifs
avaient participé à cet événement les
organisateurs en espèrent le double
cette année on écoute le président de
club du club de l'USM virofflet on prend
les enfants en inscription prè d' de 6
ans et effectivement sur les adultes
c'est 400 m de natation et euh 3 km de
course à pied on accepte effectivement
toutes les inscriptions licencier pas
licencier jeune moins jeune il y a
également des courses en relais parce
qu'on peut participer à deux
effectivement un fait la natation et
l'autre faire la course à pied et donc
les inscriptions se font jusqu'à
dimanche sur place et les dossard peut
être retiré samedi après-midi à la
piscine et dimanche matin la piscine sur
place pour s'inscrire rendez-vous
également sur le site internet qui
s'affiche également en bas de votre
écran et on poursuit avec un événement
solidaire et inclusif oui pour la 20e
semaine du handicap Montini le
Bretonneux se mobilise au programme de
ce weekend convivial des animations et
et convivial et familial autour du
handicap mais pas que vendredi c'est une
session handicap recrutement qui est
organisé dimanche un grand jeu défi en
famille au programme curling escalade
raquette ou encore atelier sur l'essence
une exposition photo sur les athlètes en
disport sera également exposée l'objet
objectif mettre en avant le partage et
l'inclusivité alors justement le partage
et l'inclusivité font aussi partie des
enjeux de la nouvelle exposition du
musée lambiné le tactile tour pose ses
valises au musée Lambinet jusqu'au 15
octobre la particularité de cette
exposition itinérante permettent à des
personnes déficientes visuelles
d'accéder à des œuvres d'art
incontournables grâce à la modélisation
3D ce qui est intéressant avec cette
exposition c'est que tous les publics
sont invités à participer avec les mains
et les yeux ça permet aussi de faire
comprendre aux aidans et au grand public
ce que vivent les personnes avec un
handicap visuel l'exposition est
proposée par l'association Valentin aui
qui agit pour l'autonomie des aveugles
et des malvoyants et vous vouliez
terminer vos idées de sortie Gabriel
avec une autre sortie qui se passe à
versaill ce weekend oui un dernier
rendez-vous à noter la fête de l'automne
des antiires se tient jusqu'au 15
octobre à Versailles c'est LE
rendez-vous incontournable pour les
antiquitaires depuis 40 ans bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ses
idées de sortie saviez-vous qu'à une
autre époque les Vikings ont foulé la
vallée de Chevreuse et bien ces derniers
sont revenu le weekend dernier ils ont
installé leur campement au château de la
Madeleine c'est le reportage de Régine
ralèche et de Louis
Douchan ici au pied du château de la
Madeleine on vous forme à l'art de la
guerre Viking pendant 2 jours une
reconstitution historique a permis aux
10000 visiteurs présents de découvrir
leur mode de vie au 9e siècle les
Vikings sont passés dans les ivelines il
y avait plusieurs camp Vikings qui
étaient sur les îles des bordde scèes
lorsqu'ils ont attaqué Paris au 9e
siècle donc c'est bien antérieur à la
période du château de la Madeleine mais
c'est une thématique qui est assez
porteuse qui plaît à beaucoup c'est
hyper important parce que bah du coup ça
représente aussi l'histoire comprendre
aussi comment on vivait à l'époque parce
qu'on est aussi dans une génération
aujourd'hui où les
enfants n'ont pas forcément notion de
tout ce qui est quotidien donc c'est
aussi important de de de transmettre au
jeunes générations une autre époque une
are vie dans ce campement plus vrai que
nature une vingtaine de bénévoles
incarnai la vie du camp ils étaient
présents afin de montrer le savoir-faire
des scandinav auxinois chacun on leur
particularités donc de base nous
représentons bah la vie en général donc
la vie de camp selon les envies et les
capacités de chacun choisissent de faire
doit soit de représenter le combat ce
qui faisait partie de leur vie aussi et
et des artisanats l'occasion de
découvrir l'ancêtre du tricot et écouter
les comptes des hommes du Nord ou venir
s'essayer à des jeux de stratégie
j'adore tout ce qui est époque médiévale
est particulièrement Viking que ça soit
histoire ou mythologie et c'est un bel
endroit en plus il fait beau et il y a
plein de gens passionnés et passionnant
cette association marli portaine le clan
Divar s'appuie sur des recherches
historiques pour proposer une expérience
immersive notre souhait c'était de faire
de la médiation culturelle autour de
l'époque doncour du peuple scandinave de
Viking c'est extrêmement important
puisque c'est l'occasion pour nous de
mettre en valeur notre patrimoine de
l'ouvrir au plus grand nombre et de
proposer des animations qui peuvent
toucher tout nos public le château de la
Madeleine proposera une nouvelle
programmation avec d'autresonstitutions
historiques sur des weekends dans les
prochains mois les dates ne sont pas
encore
communiquées et c'est bientôt l'heure de
passer à l'invité du 78 mais juste avant
je vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à
la météo de
demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir
quelques nuages dans les Yvelines
cependant il y aura tout de même
quelques éclaircis au niveau des
températures il fera très doux demain
matin 16 à rambouiller 17 à Houdan et 18
à Versailles et mont-el jolie demain
après-midi le ciel se couvre il fera
nuageux les températures seront toujours
très chaudes pour la saison 25 à 26° en
moyenne et pour les prévisions météo de
ce weekend le temps devrait rester
stable samedi nous devrions avoir de
belles éclaircis avec en moyenne 12°gr
le matin et 15°gr l'après-midi dimanche
même condition météo ça se rafraîchit un
peu le matin avec 7°gr en moyenne et
l'après-midi il fera 14°gr environ c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à l'invité
du
[Musique]
78 et nous allons parler de l'entrédent
village dans cette partie invitée avec
vous Anne bakland vous êtes responsable
de l'institut de promotion de la santé à
Saint-Quentin en iveline l'IPS qui est à
l'origine de l'entrée dans village
village alors à travers le terme aidant
comprenait des n professionnels qui
viennent en aide à une personne
dépendante de leur entourage pourquoi
organiser un événement ouvert à tous les
proches aidant et aussi les aider alors
on a mené un travail d'observation et on
a réuni les acteurs de l'accompagnement
que ce soit dans le champ du handicap ou
dans le le champ de la gérontologie qui
ont recessensé au côté des personnes
qu'elles accompagnent un certain nombre
de besoins exprimés par l'entourage donc
vous l'avez dit l'entourage c'est à la
fois les proches qu'ils soient familiaux
mais ça peut être les voisins ou les
amis d'une personne euh qu'elle soit
enfant adulte âgé qui porte un handicap
ou qui a une maladie invalidante donc au
côté de ces personnes il y a un certain
nombre de de d'aidans puisque c'est le
terme qui fait consensus aujourd'hui euh
ce qui définit cet entourage qui au côté
qui quelquefois euh apporte une aide au
quotidien très importante avec des
activités qui se cumulent et qui font
que la charge physique et mentale
s'accumule on parle même du fardeau de
l' dents il nous a semblé important de
les soutenir à travers un programme
d'action euh qui leur permette de se
réunir de parler entre eux de déposer
euh leur ressentis leur vécu dans des
rencontres et cette journée entrée d'en
village vient ponctuer ce programme en
offrant une journée spécifique destinée
à l'ensemble des aidans quels sont les
grandes difficultés que rencontrent les
aidants au quotidien vous avez parlé de
leurs besoins quels sont quels sont
leurs besoins alors je dirais qu'il y a
une pluralité d'activité il y a une
pluralité de situation et donc il y a
une pluralité desidents ce qui les
réunit c'est qu'ils accompagnent un
proche au quotidien et que les activités
elles peuvent être extrêmement
nombreuses ça peut être des aides
administratives psychologique ça peut
être les aides dans les activités du
quotidien dans l'organisation de la
journée du de l'aide au lever à
l'habillage au coucher en prenant en
compte aussi toute l'activité du repas
l'aide aux médicaments les transports
vers les les les les les professionnels
de santé donc on voit bien que c'est une
activité qui peut prendre 100 % de du
temps de de l'entourage et il nous
semblait nécessaire de pouvoir à N à
notre tour soutenir à travers un
programme d'action euh tout au long de
l'année de soutenir donc ces ces aidants
au quotidien vous on a parlé des
difficultés il y a de nombreuses tâches
est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi l'isolement
est-ce que c'est un moment également
pour les faire se rencontrer entre eux
et les faire se sentir un petit peu
moins seul finalement oui vous demandiez
quels étaient les besoins mais les
besoins ils sont multiples c'est besoins
de reconnaître les aides qui peuvent
leur être apporté aussi bien les aides
sociales que organisationnelles euh ça
peut être besoin simplement de
s'exprimer de déposer son fardeau de de
rond procède-il isolement dont vous
parlez parce que être aidant c'est
consacré souvent 100 % de son temps à à
son proche aider et ça isole beaucoup
euh et la vie sociale on sait que c'est
un déterminant de la santé donc c'est
important effectivement de provoquer ces
rencontres pour faire euh simplement
partager euh les ses difficultés son
ressenti son vécu son expérience mais
c'est aussi l'occasion aussi de de
partager aussi des stratégies qui
peuvent fonctionner et peuvent servir à
d'autres alors justement programme de
samedi il y aura des activités des
ateliers mais aussi des moments de
convivialité quels sont les moments
forts de cette journée alors cette
journée elle est pensée par tous les
acteurs qui ont contribué à à construire
le programme elle contribue surtout à à
apporter des temps récréatifs des temps
où l'on peut simplement se pososer
souffler se détendre se ressourcer
également mais c'est aussi l'occasion
aussi peut-être de redonner une place à
la personne aidée qui est souvent euh
est défin par ce qu'elle ne peut plus
faire et c'est l'occasion bah de
partager encore à travers des activités
euh des moments de de de comment dire de
de de partage et en mettant en valeur
aussi les capacités qui restent euh chez
la personne qui a une maladie
invalidante ou un handicap donc c'est
vraiment une une journée dédiée au
ressourcement mais à l'occasion de
laquelle aussi on peut trouver de
l'information utile information sur les
aides qui existent légales ext légal
c'est l' qu sont ces aides justement
alors ce sont les aides qui sont portées
essentiellement par le département qui
est chef de fil hein des politiques
publiques en terme de d'accompagnement
du handicap et de de la gérontologie
donc ça peut être des aides sous forme
financière ça peut être de l'aide
organisationnelle euh sous forme de de
de comment dire de de de service d'aide
à domicile mais ça peut être aussi des
aides techniques d'aménagement
d'adaptation du logement ou d'aide dans
simplement les activités du quotidien
donc tout cela sera rassemblé euh le
jour de l'entré dans village il aa un
comptoir des aidants pour pour informer
justement tous les aidants qui qui
veulent s'informer sur les aides qu'ils
ont à disposition voilà LE COMPTOIR DES
aidents qui sera euh animé par
l'ensemble de ces acteurs qui pourront
apporter de l'information utile sur
l'accompagnement on aura la présence du
pôle autonomie territoriale de
Saint-Quentin et de Versailles on aura
également un représentante de l'aide
sociale de l'agir Carco qui
accompagne les personnes âgées on aura
également des représentants des communes
qui mettent en place du maintien à
domicile au sein de de la ville donc on
aura un certain nombre d'acteurs et des
représentants d'usagers aussi qui
peuvent orienter vers des dispositifs
spécifiques c'est quelque chose qui
manque aujourd'hui l'information pour
les aidants alors ce qui nous est
souvent exprimé c'est voilà je suis
aidante tout d'un coup voilà je ne sais
pas comment faire je ne sais pas comment
m'organiser je ne sais pas à qui faire
appel quels sont les acteurs qui peuvent
m'accompagner comment les solliciter
quels sont leur rôles leur mission et
c'est ça que l'entrée d'un village peut
apporter aussi des réponses et alors il
sera aussi possible de participer à un
atelier de sophrologie de quelle manière
la sophrologie peut aider les aidans
alors les aidans ont la particularité
pour beaucoup en tout cas parmi ceux que
l'on rencontre de ne pas s'autoriser du
temps pour eux c'est l'occasion la
sophrologie de trouver un moyen de se
recentrer sur soi de trouver des
stratégies pour se détendre ça peut
aider aussi à retrouver le sommeil quand
il est impacté justement par la charge
mentale ou physique euh que nécessite
cet accompagnement au long cours euh
donc ce sera l'occasion effectivement de
tester ce qu'est la sophrologie de
trouver des techniques pour les
reproduire à domicile et parmi les temps
forts puisque vous posiez aussi la
question euh il y aura une pièce de euh
débat théâtral sous la forme de
représentation de différentes scénettes
qui vont représenter le quotidien des
aidans et ils pourront participer
justement pour dire c'est pas tout à
fait comme ça que les choses devraient
se passer et voilà mon idée c'est aussi
euh
euh cette occasion euh bah d'exprimer
aussi les choses et de pouvoir peut-être
modifier euh euh l'organisation à la du
domicile alors vendredi dernier la
ministre des Solidarités a exposé les
grandes lignes du plan gouvernemental
pour aider les aidanss il y a notamment
la création de 6000 places de répis
supplémentair pour assurer au moins 15
jours de répis aux aidents vous en
pensez quoi est-ce que c'est suffisant
alors suffisant je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas c'est une très bonne chose on
sait que la charge comme je le disais
est importante que les dents peut-être
déboussoler donc le répis c'est aussi où
les actions de soutien aux aidans en
général sont une manière de retrouver sa
boussole le répis c'est absolument
nécessaire parce que l'accompagnement
dans la durée peut impacter de façon
très importante l'état physique et
mental de de la personne et on sait
aujourd'hui que parmi les aidents il y
en a beaucoup qui décèdent avant leurs
proches par
manque justement de de de répis de de de
de possibilité simplement de se poser ou
de se reposer alors dernière question
autre mesure qui a été annoncée pour
simplifier le quotidien des aidanss
c'est un service public départemental
d'autonomie pour simplifier les
démarches administratives là aussi c'est
c'est essentiel C B c'est essentiel
d'avoir un interlocuteur unique alors
qui va pas apporter toutes les réponses
mais qui va pouvoir guider orienter
informer les aidents plutôt qu'il ne
cherche avec beaucoup de complexité
quelquefois quel est l'acteur qui va
pouvoir répondre à tel besoin et bien
merci beaucoup Anne bland d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau si
vous êtes intéressé l'entrée dans
village se déroule ce samedi 14 octobre
de 10h30 à 18h au château de plaisir et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité juste après ne
manquez pas votre numéro de bienvenue
dans les Evelin je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 et un bon weekend
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous